Depuis 2015, le maire de Dorval reçoit
des messages d'internautes partout au
monde. Ces message-là lui remercient d'avoir tenu
tête aux parents d'élèves musulmans qui
lui demandaient de bannir le porc des
cantines scolaires. Il y a juste un problème avec cette histoire-là,
c'est jamais arrivé. Ça a été inventé
de toutes pièces.
Je m'appelle Jeff Yates et voici l'histoire de la fausse nouvelle la plus populaire du Québec.
Vous avez peut-être vu cette publication
qui circule sur Facebook depuis quatre ans.
On salue cette « bonne initiative » d'un Québécois. Tout ça a été démenti quand ç'a commencé
à circuler en 2015. J'ai trouvé deux versions de ce même texte.
Une partagée 124 000 fois et
l'autre 178 000 fois sur Facebook.
Ces deux publications-là ont été créées après que les journalistes aient démenti l'histoire.
Juste pour vous donner une idée de l'ampleur de la chose,
l'article le plus partagés de tous les médias québécois au cours des 12 derniers mois,
C'est ce texte de « La Presse »
relayé 62 000 fois sur Facebook, donc on voit que l'histoire maire de Dorval,
c'est un monstre qui revient toujours et toujours.
Cette histoire du porc, ça s'est vraiment passé,  mais c'est arrivé en France.
En janvier 2013, les parents d'élèves de la ville d'Antibes dans le sud du pays
recevaient une lettre de la mairie. On  expliquait que le porc ne serait pas banni des cantines scolaires.
La lettre disait que certains parents
l'avaient demandé pour des raisons
religieuses ou personnelles.
C'est là que la nouvelle s'est mise à
circuler sur les réseaux sociaux.
Beaucoup de gens assumaient qu'on parlait de parents musulmans.
Un blogue nationaliste français a écrit une lettre ouverte au maire d'Antibes, Jean Leonetti, pour le féliciter.
C'est possible que cette lettre-là
vous dise quelque chose et c'est normal. La fausse nouvelle qui circule à propos
du maire de Dorval, c'est identique, c'est
le même texte.
On a tout simplement changé le nom de la ville d'Antibes pour le nom de la ville
de Dorval et si tout ce que ça a pris
pour créer la fausse nouvelle la plus
populaire du Québec.
Cette fausse nouvelle-là circule
pas juste au Québec. Elle circule un peu
partout au monde. On trouve plusieurs
versions dans plusieurs pays et dans
plusieurs langues.
D'ailleurs juste dans les dernières
semaines, l'histoire a été reprise par un
site israélien est un site de fausses
nouvelles américains.
Pas surprenant donc que le maire de
Dorval reçoive régulièrement des
messages pour le féliciter. Selon son
attaché de presse, ces messages-là
proviennent surtout d'Américains ou de gens d'ailleurs au Canada.
De plus, la depuis la section du site web de la Ville sur cette fausse nouvelle-là
a été la deuxième la plus consultée en elle n'a pu consulter en 2018.
On ne connaît pas l'identité de la personne qui a écrit cette fausse nouvelle-là,
mais une chose est  certaine, elle savait très bien ce qu'elle faisait et que c'était un mensonge.